alors vu ce que je vais avoir des propos
subversifs il faut que je commence par
une vérité nous n'avons que des juges
formidable en france simplement on est
obligé de constater que passer devant un
juge c'est avant tout un aléa et que
nous n'avons nous les avocats et les
chefs d'entreprises non plus n'ont
aucune certitude pas plus d'ailleurs que
les salariés quand il passe devant un
juge de savoir quel va être par avance
la sentence est à mon sens cela résulte
d'un constat qui va m'amener à vue une
proposition le constat commençons par
une image il ya quarante ans la médaille
des conseillers prud'hommes
c'était une médaille ou envoyer un homme
qui avait la tête baissée et la
casquette à la main qui serrés en col
roulé
le salarié qui serrer la main d'un homme
en costume la tête droite
le patron et tout le code du travail a
été conçu comme cela il a été conçu
comme un code de rapport de force entre
un homme l'employeur et qui doit qui a
la force et une personne à protéger le
salary il a été conçu comme aujourd'hui
on conçoit le code de la consommation
c'est à dire comme un code d'obligations
pour l'employeur et un code d'assistanat
pour le salarié il en résulte un certain
nombre de conséquences des normes
impératives
le code du travail est un code
d'obligations c'est pas un code
d'incitation et c'est un code aussi ce
qui est plus grave sanctionnateur à
l'égard des employeurs si bien que les
employeurs ont peur d'agir en face d'un
code du travail qui est aujourd'hui trop
compliqué qui contient trop de règles à
connaître et qui entraîne pour chacun
des sanctions il est inadmissible qu'une
personne qui se dévouent pour son
entreprise qui agit pour son entreprise
risque dans le cadre de ce dévouement et
de cette action pour cette entreprise
d'être systématiquement sanctionnés et
quand on dit sanctionné cela veut dire
aller en correctionnelle être obligé de
répondre de tel ou tel délit voilà le
constat aujourd'hui le code du travail
est un code qui est déséquilibré qui a
été conçu comme des hits
librairie la proposition pourrait être
que le ton code du travail devienne un
code avec des espaces de liberté qui à
l'intérieur de ces espaces de liberté
permettrait une négociation il en existe
des espaces de liberté dans le code du
travail
chante donne deux exemples le premier
exemple c'est qu'on vous dit les congés
payés
il existe une période de congés payés
une période obligatoire de congés payés
mais en dehors de cette période vous
pouvez prendre des congés payés c'est ça
l'incitation un autre exemple
d'incitation dans le code du travail de
possibilités d'ouverture dans le code du
travail c'est à propos de la rupture
conventionnelle la rupture
conventionnelle on vous dit simplement
il ya un plancher vous devez payer au
minimum l'équivalent de l'indemnité de
licenciement
et bien si on prenait cette base d'idées
pour réformer le code du travail que
l'on change de mentalité du code du
travail que l'on cherche à créer des
fourchettes des possibilités des espaces
de liberté on ouvrirait d'une part le
champ à la négociation d'une manière
beaucoup plus large premièrement et
aussi on éviterait que le juge
sanctionne parce que le juge ait un rôle
très simple à partir du moment où la
règle n'est pas respectée il doit
sanctionner il doit en tirer les
conséquences et aujourd'hui il n'est pas
possible qu'un juge ne tire pas les
conséquences d'une règle qui n'est pas
respecté donc en élargissant la règle du
code du travail en élargissant la règle
impérative
on pourrait ainsi arriver à créer des
espaces de liberté des espaces de
négociation
je vous donne un exemple on parle tous
de la durée du travail de la durée
légale du travail plus exactement parce
que la durée exacte du travail n'est pas
la durée légale et tout le monde se base
sur un chiffre tantôt 35 ans 37 entre 39
avant 40
mais pourquoi elles ne créeront pas une
fourchette de déré de durée légale du
travail entre 35 et 42 heures par
exemple
en suisse on travaille quarante deux
heures et demie une votation qui a
refusé de passer en dessous
le minimum c'est la france est avec 35
pourquoi ne créeront pas des fourchettes
comme cela durée légale du travail doit
être négocié dans l'entreprise
dans la branche dans ailleurs entre 35
et 42 eur et pourquoi ne laisserai ton
pas non plus dans le cadre de la
négociation
un peu plus d espace de liberté à la
négociation individuelle entre
l'employeur et le salarié
quand on parle de négociations
collectives
on parle de négociations collectives
pour les grandes entreprises mais quand
on est dans les toutes petites
entreprises
la négociation collective elle la
négociation elle se passe tous les jours
tous les jours entre l'employeur et
l'employé et vouloir créer faire
intervenir un syndicat pour aller
négocier à l'intérieur d'une entreprise
de moins de dix salariés c'est une
absurdité parce que la négociation se
passe tous les jours elle se passe
effectivement et en laissant un peu d
espace de liberté également dans le
contrat de travail dans le cadre de
cette négociation on permettrait ainsi
d'ouvrir des champs des champs plus
large et de permettre que le code du
travail ne soit plus un code
sanctionnateur mais un code incitateur
merci beaucoup on parle souvent quand on
parle de justice on parle également de
temps delà de la justice est-ce qu'il
faut tenter de réduire ce que le temps
est trop long devant sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne judiciaire escaut si les les
accords internationaux
nous sommes pris et on l'a vu tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure en parlait de de
l'oit et des conventions de l'oit et il
ya beaucoup de conventions de l'oit et
qui entre en droit français
il ya beaucoup de directives européennes
de règlement européenne qui s'imposent à
nous est ce qu'il n'ya pas souvent une
sorte de une forme de troc sur
transposition est ce que l'avocat vous
êtes tous les avocats que vous êtes les
uns et les autres pour un certain nombre
ne souffrait pas de de cela oui
écoutez on s'est aperçu à propos des
accords d'annualisation qu'il y avait un
tel un empilement de règles aussi bien
interne qu'international que pour des
accords d'annualisation qui avait été
définies au niveau de la branche la cour
de cassation en utilisant cet empilement
de règles a considéré que ces accords ne
et est inopposable et par conséquent à
écarter les accords d'annualisation et a
permis ainsi aux salariés qui prétendait
ne pas voir cet accord lui être
opposable des heures supplémentaires
alors que il y avait au départ une
situation contractuelle qui avait été
parfaitement définis entre l'employeur
et le salarié
on voit donc qu'un empilement de règles
impératives peut arriver par un effet
quasiment mécanique quasiment
automatique à nuire à ce qu'ils étaient
le contrat de base entre l'employeur et
l'employé